welcome to exploring computing
today's video is introduction to html
origins of the web so in this video
we're going to take a look at where the
worldwide web comes from
i think having an understanding of the
background
of why the world wide web is created and
where it comes from is going to give you
a better sense of what's actually going
on when we take a look at how the web
works
and when you see what some of the
limitations are and some of the oddities
involved with the web
so the world wide web comes from two
basic technologies the first one is the
internet
which we've spent quite a bit of time
studying over the last couple lectures
and the second one is a technology
called hypertext and so we're going to
start off by taking a look at hypertext
the basic idea behind hypertext is how
are we going to present
information for people and we've been
using the book for
forever and so the question is what are
the limitations of the book
and what might we want to do to replace
it and this is a question that
information scientists have been
thinking about for quite some time
and in fact we started thinking about
how information technology might provide
a good replacement for books
right around the end of world war ii so
there's a famous article by van over
bush
called as we may think and that came out
in 1945.
now as i mentioned one of the key
technologies behind the web is hypertext
the beginnings of hypertext and
hypermedia actually date back to 1963.
probably the first widespread use of
hypertext and hypermedia were electronic
encyclopedias found on cd-roms
microsoft and carta starting in 1993
provides a really good example of this
uses that technology and the worldwide
web first came out in 1989
which you'll note actually precedes
microsoft and cardiff but it was only
in use by a very limited number of
people and we'll be taking a look at
that
in a couple of minutes all right so
what's wrong with the book
why would we want to replace it well one
thing about a book is
a book consists of pages and each of the
pages follows a preceding page
sequentially i mean that's fairly
obvious but
it turns out this can be a pretty big
limitation it really depends on what
sort of
book we're looking at so we have page
one followed by page two followed by
page three and so on
and we're reading fiction this is
probably a good choice
unless let's say it's a mystery novel
and you just can't
handle waiting till the end and so you
flip to the end to see what's going on
or
possibly you're a literary criticism
major and you want to jump around the
book but most of us are perfectly happy
with
the linear nature of fiction
novels in contrast think about something
like an encyclopedia because an
encyclopedia
is printed it's got that single
sequential
information flow so if we're looking for
an article on
the reverend martin luther king we're
likely to find him
sandwiched between king george of
england and king philip
of spain what does he have to do with
those two well the encyclopedia
only has one ordering of information and
it uses that linear ordering of
information to make it easy to look up
articles
not to find links between different
and so when we move to computers we're
no longer limited to that single
ordering of information
we can create different nodes of
information and link any node to any
other node
so we can still maintain our sequence of
information for lookup
if we wanted to but we could also link
director martin luther king to articles
on the civil rights movement to selma
alabama
to great leaders of the 20th century and
so on
we now have a web of information which
is where the term worldwide web comes
from of course
and this concept of hypertext basically
said that we have these different
text nodes and that we're going to link
the text nodes
and of course this is exactly how the
world wide web works
we can take things a step further on the
computer because we're no longer limited
to just text
we can have speeches
we can have audio so we can have the
reverend martin luther
king's i have a dream speech we can have
photographs we can have movies
and so this is called hypermedia okay so
that's the basic idea behind hypertext
and hypermedia
but that still doesn't get us the
worldwide web yet that's only half the
equation we've seen that the other half
of the equation is the internet but
how did the two end up together well we
need to move to europe
and in europe there's a physics
consortium called
cern it has 23 member countries
and its main headquarters in geneva
it's most famous for a large collider
which is used for high energy physics
not that different from our very own
stanford slack
and in this case they have a 27
kilometer ring which is used for high
energy physics and smashing particles
into each other
now in the late 80s one of the computer
scientists working for cern was
interested in coming up with a way for
the physicists
at cern to share research papers one of
the things that happens at cern is
the member countries send their
physicists to cern and then sometimes
they return to
their own institutions in their various
countries and
so he was looking for a way to share
papers between all the physicists
and naturally he thought we should use
the internet but in addition
he thought we should use that hypertext
technology that people have been talking
about
and it's been sitting on a research lab
for quite some time and nobody's
actually
using if you hear some tinkling in the
background that is actually maddie
drinking from her
dog ball and her her dog tags hitting
the dog bowl
anyway so tim berners-lee in 1989 came
up with this idea of combining
the internet with hypertext in order to
share information between physicists
and this is the origin of the world wide
web he was knighted for it in 2004.
so i think it's important when you look
at the world wide web and you wonder why
some of the things
work the way they do on the world wide
web it was originally invented to allow
physicists to share
physics research papers and so it didn't
really have
the sort of technologies we might want
for
widespread mass media usage we'll see
that some of them have been tacked on
but there's still some things that like
i think if you were designing the system
specifically
for mass market and for regular
consumers
you might have come up with a slightly
different formalism for
how the addresses work and we are going
to see that
there's a lot of stuff that had to get
added in order to
provide for much more colorful much more
interesting web pages than
you might expect to see in a physics
paper all right so in the next video
we're going to take a look at
html which is actually the language used
to create web pages
i'll talk to you soon